giving day and the red cross knows
nevadans won't disappoint they're asking
for your help
because now more than ever blood
donations are crucial
christian excuse me i almost butchered
your name christian joins us live from
sahara west library to explain more on
this
hey guys that's right good afternoon
we're here live
in the cross streets between sahara and
grand canyon and we're basically
partnering up with the red cross today
on this
giving day where folks basically are
coming out to do donations of all types
whether it be money donations or
blood donations check out the scene here
inside the library basically all the
folks out here
are very busy all the volunteers helping
people as they're coming out here to do
their donation now
this year the need is extra because of
the pandemic the red cross is looking
for people who have recovered from the
virus because
their blood contains the antibod
antibodies
that can help others battling the virus
now the very first step
is to check out the red cross blog
redcrossblood.org to see if
you are eligible to make a donation and
then obviously you can go ahead
and make an appointment now there are
several ways to help you can be a
volunteer you can go out and make
a financial donation or the best kind is
to give
blood you can also take a class and
basically that way you can also
participate
and help save lives remember that help
can't wait during an emergency
and that's why we need your support to
ensure that families don't face
any emergency alone visit 8newsnow.com
for more information for now
we're going to be out here there's still
plenty of slots to come out and do a
donation remember
it's very important for you to make that
donation so get on that eight
newsnow.com website
and book it right now christian concert
is 8 news now good stuff christian
thanks a lot